i don't want your pity i want change
jacob blake's sister
speaks out after her brother was shot in
the back
multiple times by police in kenosha
wisconsin on sunday
so many people have reached out to me
telling me
they're sorry that this happened to my
family
well don't be sorry because this has
been happening to my family
for a long time longer than i can
account for
on tuesday lotra widman delivered a
powerful message
demanding change it happened
to emmett till emmett till is my family
philando mike brown sandra
this has been happening to my family and
i've shared cheers for every single one
of these people that it's happened to
shortly after the moving speech celebs
weighed in
gabrielle union retweeting the clip and
asking fans to please watch
and listen i'm not sad
i'm not sorry i'm angry
and i'm tired i haven't cried one
time i stopped crying years ago
i am numb i have been watching police
murder people that look like me for
years
graphic video footage of the incident
shows 29 year old blake
who was reportedly trying to break up a
fight when police arrived on the scene
walking away from officers before being
shot in the back
blake was transported to a hospital in
milwaukee
in serious condition and the officers on
the scene were later placed on
administrative leave
the news has sparked protests all across
the country
and stars have been vocal about the
police shooting on social media
beyonce shared this pic of blake with
his children on instagram wednesday
writing sending prayers and thoughts to
jacob blake and his family
kevin hart tweeted in part quote another
black man shot multiple times by police
officers
it's shoot first and detained second in
these streets
lebron james echoed that sentiment
writing this
is so wrong and so sad feels so sorry
for him
his family and our people we want
justice
camila cabello shared the family pick of
blake on instagram
writing that she has no words demi
lovato called on fans to demand
justice while aisha tyler summed it all
up on twitter
writing he was trying to break up a
fight he wasn't
armed he was relieved police had arrived
to handle the fight so he went to get in
his car
and drive his children safely home they
shot him seven
times in the back in front of his
children say his name
jacob blake
you